un terremoto de magnitud 6,8 el más
potente que ha afectado a China en casi
una década el sismo se registró el lunes
Poco después del mediodía hora local
cerca de kanding una región montañosa
del país a 39 kilómetros del epicentro
la ciudad de luding ha sido devastada
los equipos de rescate trabajan sin
descanso buscando entre los escombros en
busca de supervivientes
esta mujer Es una de las afortunadas
rescatada entre los escombros Juan tian
june miembro del cuerpo de policía
armada de sichuan Se comprometió con
operaciones de rescate eficientes y
agregó que los damnificados recibirán
ayuda haremos un buen trabajo en el
reasentamiento de las personas y el
trabajo de salud y prevención de
epidemias la zona afectada no está
densamente poblada pero el número de
víctimas ya es elevado muchos muertos y
docenas de desaparecidos una cifra de
muertos que podría aumentar dada la
magnitud del terremoto que se ha sentido
a 200 kilómetros de distancia en la
ciudad de chengdu donde 21 millones de
habitantes están actualmente encerrados
debido a un brote de Kobe 19 más de mil
soldados y oficiales del ejército han
sido movilizados para ayudar en la
situación el presidente chino dice que
espera limitar la pérdida de vidas
[Música]
escenas que traen dolorosos recuerdos de
un poderoso terremoto en sichuan en 2008
de 7,9 de magnitud que dejó 87 mil
muertos